désolé on va complète benoît richard vie
de plein fouet la hausse des prix des
intrants sur sa ferme engrais semences
emballages tout a augmenté
il a choisi de ne pas vendre ses
produits à montréal prix de l'essence
oblige ce que l'on a on reste local
local local on s'agrandit pas trop on a
commencé les marchés puis on voit que
les gens sont plus en plus réticents
parce que je suis obligé de monter
mépris les gens sont pas habitués à ce
l'an dernier ils vendaient 6 e pour
trois dollars la douzaine il faisait 1 $
de profits cette année il doit les
vendre à 4 $ et 50 et fait des profits
de 30 scène
constat similaire chez d'autres
producteurs il ya de moins en moins de
places en fait pour les bénéfices est de
plus en plus de dépenses pour tous ce
qu'est un train en matériel de
production chauffage on essaie aussi le
profane le coût du propane pour nous ça
a été considérable cette année mais les
producteurs maraîchers peuvent
difficilement affiché une hausse
drastique du prix de leurs produits
parce qu'il faut quand même rester à
l'affût de tout ce que nos compétiteurs
ou encore les grossistes affiche compris
c'est du jamais vu selon l'association
des producteurs maraîchers du québec qui
estime entre 30 % et 50 % la hausse des
coûts de production par rapport à l'an
dernier c'est inquiétant comme phénomène
actuellement parce que c'est la deuxième
année de suite la convie une
augmentation fulgurante des prix des
intrants l'union des producteurs
agricoles demandent une aide spécifique
de québec on remarque d'ailleurs
grandement
sur un camp d'urgence pour les
entreprises agricoles quelque chose de
rare et à terme programmée des
liquidités au niveau des entreprises le
ministre de l'agriculture ne prévoit pas
dead supplémentaire aux programmes déjà
existants le placez vraiment s'assurer
que les les outils qu'on à la
disposition le puisse très bien répondre
dans le contexte actuel comme plusieurs
producteurs benoît richard compte
s'adapter aux alliés de son métier je
pense qu'on va faire assez d'argent pour
survivre mais pas de l'oas pouvoir
s'acheter de la machinerie de son âme en
profiter pour des vacances quoi que ce
soit il garde espoir pour les jours
meilleurs
ici marc isabelle roche radio canada
montréal